the year was 1816 Europe and North
America had just been through a
devastating series of wars and a slow
recovery seemed to be underway but
Nature had other plans after two years
of poor harvests the spring brought
heavy rains and coal flooding the rivers
and causing crop failures from the
British Isles to Switzerland while odd
colored snow fell in Italy and Hungary
famine food riots and disease epidemics
ensued meanwhile New England was
blanketed by a strange fog that would
not disperse as the ground remained
frozen well into June in what came to be
known as the year without a summer some
thought the apocalypse had begun a mood
captured in Lord Byron's poem darkness I
had a dream which was not all a dream
the bright Sun was extinguished and the
stars did wander darkling in the eternal
space rayless and pathless and the icy
earth swung blind and blackening in the
moonless air morn came and went and came
and brought no day they had no way of
knowing that the real source of their
misfortunes had occurred a year ago
thousands of miles away the 1815
eruption of Mount Tambora on the
Indonesian island of Samoa was what is
known as a supervolcano
characterized by a volume of erupted
material many times greater than that of
ordinary volcanoes and while the popular
image of volcanic destruction is molten
rock engulfing the surrounding land far
greater devastation is caused by what
remains in the air volcanic ash
dispersed by wind can blanket the sky
for days while toxic gases such as
sulfur dioxide react in the stratosphere
blocking out solar radiation and
drastically cooling the atmosphere below
the resulting volcanic winter along with
other effects such as acid rain can
affect multiple continents disrupting
natural cycles and annihilating the
plant life on which other organisms
including humans
the
releasing nearly a hundred and sixty
cubic kilometers of rock ash and gas the
Mount Tambora eruption was the largest
in recorded history
causing as many as ninety thousand
deaths but previous eruptions have been
even more deadly the 1600 eruption of
Peru's wine abu tina is likely to have
triggered the russian famine that killed
nearly two million while more ancient
eruptions have been blamed for major
world events such as the fall of the
Chinese Shah dynasty the disappearance
of the Minoan civilization and even a
genetic bottleneck in human evolution
that may have resulted from all but a
few thousand human beings being wiped
out 70,000 years ago one of the most
dangerous types of supervolcano is an
explosive caldera formed when a volcanic
Mountain collapses after an eruption so
large that the now-empty magma chamber
can no longer support its weight but
though the above-ground volcano is gone
the underground volcanic activity
continues with no method of release
magma and volcanic gases continue to
accumulate and expand underground
building up pressure until a massive and
violent explosion becomes inevitable and
one of the largest active volcanic
calderas lies right under Yellowstone
National Park the last time it erupted
650,000 years ago it covered much of
North America in nearly two meters of
Ash and rock scientists are currently
monitoring the world's active volcanoes
and procedures for predicting eruptions
conducting evacuations and diverting
lava flows have improved over the years
but the massive scale and global reach
of a supervolcano means that for many
people there would be nowhere to run
fortunately the current data shows no
evidence of such an eruption occurring
in the next few thousand years but the
idea of a sudden and unavoidable
civilization destroying apocalypse
caused by events half a global way will
remain a powerful and terrifying vision
less fictional than we would like to
believe
the winds were withered in the stagnant
air and the clouds perished darkness had
no need of aid from them
she was the universe
you